BACKSTROM A GOAL AND AN ASSIST
IN AN OVERTIME LOSS IN EDMONTON
GETTING HIM TO
CARLSON A CHEHES GARLAND, IN FR,
OFF OF THE SKATE OF
ELIAS PETTERSSON AND NOW WIDE OF
THE GOAL.
AND
HERE NOW OVECHKIN WITH THE SHOT
KUZNETSOV, A SHARP-ANGLED SHOT
OFF OF A STICK, NOW WIDE OF THE.
THAT IS JUST A BAD HOP.
MOTTE ON THE IN.
IF NOT ALREADY OVER THE LINE,EE.
>> John S.: I DON'T KNOW.
>> John G.: THAT, I THINK, IS
PR
SHOT WIDE AND THEY'VE GIVEN
KUZNETSOV THEANUCKS ARE DIGGINGE
PUCK IN THE WASHINGTON ZONE AND
TO THE VANCOUVER BLUE LINE AND
DEFENSIVE PLAY BOESER.
ORLOV, OVECHKIN, SWEEPING IT, IN
FRONT, BLOCKED, ORLOV,,HAT
PUCK OFF OF THE SKATE OFF 8:30 S
IT GO AND ONE THROUGH.
GOING TO THE MILLER
AFTER IT.
BACK TO
CANUCKS WITH THE PUCK, OFF THE
DRAW NOW MILLER, TURNS, MOVING
FACE-OFF.
AND HERE NOW THE PUCK, GOING
ITHO
POINTS, HISD HIS
FRONT AND IT IS GARLAND NOW
AFTER THAT PUCK, FAR BOARDS AND
NOW DIVING
PLAY, CONOR GARLAND.
KEEPING THE PLAY VANECEK, AND IS
MYERS NOW,
TO OVECHKIN.
NEARSIDE NOW, KUZNETSOV, BACK TO
KARLSSON, OVECHKIN A THERE,
TAKING THAT PASS.
TU GAMES
DECIDED IN THE THREE-ON-TH AWAY.
THE CAPITALS NOW TWO-ON-ONE
CARLSON